what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so a few things first and foremost
I had intended to finish Green Lantern
blackest night by the time Halloween
ended but then I was going through and I
was like well we haven't really done
anything with like the Green Lantern
tie-in or the Green Lantern Corps now
the funny thing about this is that the
the Green Lantern mythos is just largely
those two titles that's really all it is
they cross over in terms of like big
events like Sinestro Corps war different
things like that but usually they tell
two distinctly different stories from
two distinctly different perspectives
the issue I ran into is we wouldn't be
able to have the entirety of blackest
night done by the time we finished all
the tions if we kept it every Sunday
when Halloween rolls around so we're
doing it in our DC days we get three
Green Lantern videos a week I guess
three blackest night videos a week
rather so if you've loved like it's
night you're gonna be hyped we're still
gonna keep our DC rebirth stuff so we're
gonna have to double upload which works
because like for the next couple weeks
it'll basically be Green Lantern
blackest night and dark nights metal on
the DC days so ah I'm sure a lot of you
guys will be over the moon in terms of
the stuff that we're gonna be doing but
again blackest night really comes out of
the events of Sinestro Corps war that's
really all this is and that's why
Sinestro Corps war is so important one
of the things that we learned over the
course of geoff johns entire run of
Green Lantern is that there was this
prophecy called the prophecy of blackest
night and the idea was that over the
course of the existence of the universe
these different cores would come into
existence the red lanterns would come
into existence and the blue lanterns
were come into existence and the star
sapphires and the you know indigo tribe
and all that kind of stuff all these
lanterns would rise to prominence most
all of them would be super obscure and
almost nobody would know about them save
for the Green Lantern's themselves and
in the Sinestro Corps when they rose to
power during the events of Sinestro
Corps war but the prophecy of blackest
night basically stated that there would
be this war of light among all the
lantern cores and the result is that the
black lanterns would basically rise and
then eliminate all life in the universe
and that's exactly what's happening the
guardians of the universe some of the
most powerful beings in existence knew
about the prophecy of blackest night
they believed the prophecy of blackest
night was fear mongering it was an
attempt to strip Green Lantern's of
their power by instilling in them this
belief that the universe would come to
an end and all these Lantern cores would
rise
in doing so Green Lanterns would cease
to be as powerful as they once were
paving the way for almost any number of
other villains to rise to power now
because of that when Sinestro Corps war
popped off and in the aftermath of
Sinestro Corps war once we got into
Infinite Crisis and those storylines and
once the black Lantern's started to rise
the guardians of the universe kind of
looked around and said well I guess they
were right the problem is that this
created a rift of sorts because a couple
of the guardians named ganthet and sayd
always believed the prophecy was going
to come into existence and so in order
to prepare for it they created the Blue
Lantern cores and the Blue Lantern just
kind of existed out there the fact
remains here that in the presence of all
these black lantern rings when we began
covering blackest night we've basically
data issues one through four and then
stopped and started doing tie-ins the
reason for that is because everything
that we're covering right now in terms
of these tie-ins really until I say
otherwise this is all taking place
during the first four issues of blackest
night the other half of this is that
almost everybody is encountering this in
their own way at the outset the Green
Lantern Corps is encountering all this
stuff at the outset how Jordan and those
guys are on earth they're encountering
it Jon Stewart is actually just sort of
pondering the nature of the mistakes
that he's made when it came to the
planet of zhanchi now we talked about
this before between 1988 and 1989 DC
published a story called cosmic Odyssey
it was a four part series and it was
weird it was a really really weird story
written by jim Starlin but it basically
detailed this idea that there was just
some being called an t life more or less
that it's split itself into four parts
and it had gone to four different
planets but the idea of was that jon
stewart was a relatively new and pretty
reckless Green Lantern when he was
younger and the result was that he
teamed up with Martian Manhunter to try
to find a way to basically keep zhanchi
from being destroyed doing to the fact
that if two of these planets were
obliterated the universe would be
destroyed in its entirety he basically
screwed up ran headlong into have found
this giant bomb in the middle of the
planet was too late to save it and
everybody on the planet died now the
funny thing about Jon Stewart is that he
is basically a Green Lantern
that did not initially rise to any real
significant measure of popularity until
justice Lee came out in 2001 he was
introduced thirty years earlier in 1971
he basically served as a backup
character throughout the entirety of the
Green Lantern run running all the way up
through Emerald Isle I'd he had involve
in all those stories you're our crisis
and time and so on and so forth up into
a Green Lantern rebirth which is where
he began to increase in popularity even
more among color book readers just
because of the fact that his popularity
in Justice League the cartoon show and
then Green Lantern rebirth basically set
him to one of the higher echelons of
characters but the idea here is that
because of the fact that zan she was a
planet that he obliterated what this
does is it basically tells us that there
is no limit to what it is that the Black
Lantern race can resurrect they can
recreate anything zhanchi itself is
resurrected as an entire planet to serve
the purpose of operating alongside the
black Lantern's now this will eventually
go into like Jon Stewart's own sub story
that will lead into the main blackest
night story and actually see him do some
pretty cool stuff what we end up doing
here is we switch over to xamarin where
the home of the star sapphires as well
as the Sinestro Corps now one thing to
keep in mind is in the aftermath of the
Sinestro Corps war there were a couple
of things that had taken place the first
is that Sinestro himself had basically
been defeated and captured and the
result was that the Green Lantern's were
intent on taking him back to OA
to be put on trial the problem with this
was that in the middle of it all the
Green Lantern's were ambushed by a
combination of the red lanterns those
who you know survived the Sinestro Corps
war and even the blue lanterns
themselves and it led into this great
big huge conflict which I have a video
on that you can check out down in the
description this is stuff that I suggest
you check out the Green Lantern playlist
just to get the full you know
explanation of it but the idea was that
Atrocitus the leader of the red lanterns
so we wanted to obliterate all lanterns
in existence why don't you just get rid
of them all in their entirety the idea
was that this led into a series of
skirmishes that took place between the
the Sinestro Corps the red lanterns the
blue lanterns the Green Lantern's in
addition to all this one of the members
of the Sinestro Corps named Amon Sewer
the son of a bansuri first gave Hal
Jordan his Green Lantern a Mansoor had
basically eliminated the entire family
of one of the Green Lantern's and the
result was that this lanterns friend had
basically discovered what was going on
and in her wrath killed Amon Sewer
despite the fact that he was basically
surrendering the result was that Lyra
herself was ousted from the Green
Lantern's and in her rage was given a
Red Lantern ring and then that led into
the whole skirmish of the Green Lantern
showing up now Sinestro being captured
so on and so forth in an effort to
basically try to
Lyra away from being a Red Lantern
because of the fact that she was one of
the original Green Lantern's faul
Sinestro had actually killed her
while Howard was trying to reason with
her Hal Jordan eventually became a Red
Lantern different things like that but
this all basically goes towards this
idea that the Sinestro Corps itself was
experiencing what amounted to a civil
war in the sense that you had thousand
Esther who had finally been captured by
the Green Lantern's and was being held
prisoner while that was going on a
villain named Mongol who is by and large
as strong if not stronger than Superman
depending on what stories you're reading
was given a yellow lantern ring himself
and then basically co-opted leadership
of the Sinestro Corps and took it over
in sinestro's absence and so what you
basically had were members of the
Sinestro Corps who were loyal to Mongol
and those who were loyal to Sinestro the
result was that when everything popped
off and when everything started going to
pot and it all started going awry
Sinestro made his escape he was out he
grabbed those who were faithful and then
tracked down the star sapphires which
leads us here now the reason why he's
here for these star sapphires is because
of the fact that these star sapphires
are based on love and so what they did
is they took a whole bunch of members of
the Sinestro Corps and they started
putting them in these crystals of sorts
that would basically convert them to
star sapphires Sinestro showing up here
simply serves the purpose of grabbing
you know his members of the Sinestro
Corps bringing them back and then
eventually going back killing Mongol and
then taking back over his Sinestro Corps
again with this idea of the Red Lanterns
transitioning back to Islam this is
still the aftermath of all this stuff
Lyra still dead the Green Lantern's are
still trying to make their escape
they're dealing with the Red Lanterns
themselves and then suddenly Black
Lantern rings just start descending on
everyone so again that's why there's so
much back and forth here that's why
there's so much jumping around is
because we're talking about a war across
the universe with these black lantern
rains seemingly showing up out of
nowhere now the other half of this is
that star sapphires effectively have the
ability to tap into the emotions of
people by way of love and in attempt
that's made by Carol Farris who was
formerly a lover of Hal Jordan the first
star sapphire and then ultimately
rechristened with the star sapphire Jim
again is that she had actually encased
Sinestro in this crystal of love more or
less and tried to convert him or tried
to begin the process of converting him
now under normal circumstances what
happens is that if a person is not
powerful enough when they're encased in
crystal they'll basically just kind of
begin to shut down going
to a comatose state and the conversion
process will begin but they can still
resist it they can refute the conversion
this is designed to show us how powerful
Sinestro is that were the other members
of the Sinestro Corps are trying to
resist this conversion and it's taking
quite a lot of time for it to happen as
soon as he's put into a crystallized by
Carol Farris he immediately shatters out
of it because it's basically this idea
that he is in a lot of ways though
walking talking living embodiment of
fear now the problem with this is that
in the middle of their skirmish much
like the skirmish between the Red
Lanterns and the Green Lantern's and all
that stuff we're basically met with the
arrival of the Black Lanterns and so
again that's why I say all this takes
place over the course of the first four
issues is because this is basically all
these different groups in the middle of
their ongoing conflicts basically in the
middle of this war of light and then
suddenly the black lanterns start
appearing out of nowhere the other half
of this is the orange lantern Larfleeze
who's basically kind of an outlier when
it comes to all the lantern cores that
exist in DC Comics they effectively have
this governing rule in the sense that
only those who are able to overcome
great fear can become Green Lantern's
only those who are basically able to
manipulate fear and use that fear to
empower themselves can become Sinestro
Corps members so on and so forth
Larfleeze is not like any of the other
cores Larfleeze is the orange lantern of
greed of avarice and so the idea is that
he has the whole of the Lantern Corps
power to himself which makes him insane
in terms of the kind of things that he
can do but the idea here is that because
the blue lanterns were so intriguing to
Larfleeze when the opportunity arose
which we had covered previously for him
to basically capture the blue lanterns
when he was introduced to the idea that
they exist he basically took all of his
constructs and just sent them all
directly to the blue lanterns themselves
now that's the inherent difference
between Larfleeze as an orange Lantern
and everybody else all the other Lantern
cores have multiple members the blue
lanterns the red lanterns the green
lanterns yellow lanterns but with
Larfleeze his core is consists of
constructs anyone he's ever killed
becomes a construct they become
something for him to control the problem
with this is that again with Larfleeze
having killed so many people his base of
operations is a giant graveyard it means
when Black Lantern rings started
descending under Larfleeze base of
operations it's nothing
but black lanterns that start rising
everywhere it's just him by himself but
his power is extreme and will actually
find out just how powerful he is
in the next few videos or so but the
idea is that again this is why the blue
lanterns are fighting the orange
lanterns is because it's the constructs
of Larfleeze trying to overpower the
blue lanterns and then take their rings
from them so we can just hoard the Rings
for himself it's just this giant
treasure trove you know that he
essentially keeps around and so the idea
here is that with this war of light
going on with the black lanterns rising
themselves what it does is it begins to
shift its focus to the idea of the
Indigo tribe now Before we jump into
that what we actually end up doing is
picking up with a Green Lantern Corps
line of stories which is to say all the
other green lanterns that are out there
- Hal Jordan and the idea here is that
this picks up in the aftermath of a
story called emerald Eclipse now it will
eclipse we didn't cover we didn't really
have a reason to you just because the
entire basis of the story we could
explain later on within the span of five
or six minutes but the whole idea of
emeral Eclipse is it was basically DC
finally finding a way to deal with the
character of sodam yacht's those of you
guys who don't know so to me odd is
what's called a daksa might and daksa
mites live on the planet dachshund
somewhere along the line in DC's history
some Kryptonians basically left the
planet of Krypton and then took up
residence on Dax on over time they
basically became xenophobic the result
is that as time progressed if somebody
from another were another planet or
something like that showed up on their
home they would basically be destroyed
or something along those lines so DeMott
hails from that race of people much like
Superman if he's exposed to a Yellow Sun
he'll develop Superman powers the idea
was that as a child he had come across
what amounted to a spacefaring Explorer
crash landing on his homeworld and his
actual existence was kept hidden away
from everybody just so that they
wouldn't you know freak out when he was
there but through this explore so tomate
learned about the greater universe about
the Green Lantern Corps and all these
different races that exist out there and
someone is so forth the problem was that
when this Explorer was discovered he was
basically taken killed and stuffed by
the dachshunds themselves this created
an absolute hatred for his own race and
their xenophobic views at the hands of
so DeMott in response to this when he
was given the opportunity to become a
Green Lantern he immediately took it now
he became significant in the Green
Lantern mythos for two reasons the first
is because it was believed
if someone like Superman ever became a
Green Lantern they'd be the most
powerful Lantern in existence because
it's basically the powers of Superman
combined with the powers of a lantern
ring and so that would be hitherto
almost unchecked powers the other half
of this is that he was destined to
become the new I on when DC originally
launched the events of Emerald Twilight
and a zero hour crisis and time how
Jordan became possessed by parallax all
that kind of good stuff he eliminated
almost the entirety of the Green Lantern
Corps Kyle Rayner basically became a
being called ion which basically allowed
him to house the entity in the sense
that he was basically able to
single-handedly resurrect the entirety
of the Green Lantern's that's what the
ion entity is should all the Green
Lantern's be killed the ion can bring
them all back he can basically bring
back the guardians and the central power
battery and all that kind of stuff the
whole idea is that because sodam yacht
was so powerful during the events of
Mongol running the Sinestro Corps he
basically invaded the planet of Daxton
sodam yacht intervened and in the midst
of it all basically took the red Sun or
flew himself into the red Sun and then
use his own energies and converted it
into a yellow Sun gave all of his people
Superman powers and they fought off the
Sinestro Corps and that's basically it
that's the gist of it but the idea is
that he was believed to have been left
for dead he was believed to have died
now he didn't and he'll come back during
the events of brightest day but at the
time he was believed to have been gone
and it allowed DC to put him on the back
burner but while there isn't a whole lot
of meat and potatoes to the Green
Lantern Corps story what this basically
does or at least in terms of this story
is it deals with the idea that with
these Black Lantern rings descending on
all these different people everybody's
having to deal with it in their own way
for the character of Kyle Rayner he
basically sees this sort of
reincarnation of the character Jade the
daughter of the Green Lantern Allen
Scott who how Reiter had been in love
with and who had ultimately died because
of the fact that Jade alongside almost
all the other girlfriends that he's had
have all perished in tragic
circumstances it's a haunting factor of
Kyle Rayner that's one of the reasons
why he never really gets into
relationships or if he does it's tedious
because for him he's always afraid the
girlfriend he has is gonna get
quote-unquote stuffed in a refrigerator
that's the big concern that goes on in
his mind when it comes to other people
the other half of this is it actually
shows how sadistic the Black Lanterns
are in the sense that they actually bust
into a infirmary for the most part where
all these Green Lanterns are healing
from various injuries the conflicts
they've been in and they
literally go in and just start tearing
out their hearts I mean it's pretty
intense in terms of what it is that they
end up doing here but again this is the
first appearance of the black lantern
rings to a vast majority of the Green
Lantern Corps so again it's pretty cool
in terms of how it all unfolds but
jumping back to Sinestro our Jimmy back
to the black lantern so the fact that
these black lanterns are basically
emerging two of the most important ones
come in the form of Amon sword and
Aaron's sword now Aaron soar was at one
time
the only person that Sinestro had
actually loved and cirrhotic not to you
is the daughter of Aaron soar and
Sinestro himself we learned that during
the events of I want to say it was when
the Red Lanterns captured Sinestro
himself but the idea here is that facing
off against these black Lantern's keep
in mind the black Lantern's themselves
basically feed on emotion the whole idea
is that they are basically emotional
batteries in the sense that they force
all these different people they come
across to feel fear or rage whatever the
case may be and those emotions charge up
that person's heart and when that
person's heart is charged the black
Lantern's take their hearts consume them
and all that energy feeds the central
power battery the reason why that's
important is because when the central
power battery is at 100% the entity that
represents the Black Lantern Corps is
necron himself and it will allow him to
enter the realm of the living that's why
this is a huge deal and so again that's
why this is so huge is because in the
middle of this all the Indigo tribe
finally steps in and the whole goal here
is for them to essentially be the voice
of reason the voice of logic and they
will be the ones who will basically come
together and say we have to unite the
Lantern cores against the blackest night
we cannot let them battle because if we
do then what this will do is it will
basically live up to the prophecy and so
with that in mind the Indigo tribe
indigo one at least the leader of the
Indigo tribe basically grabs Sinestro
and takes them directly to Mangal
because the whole idea here is to
eliminate Mangal and reunite the
Sinestro Corps because they need every
single living member of every single
Lantern Corps and more to defeat the
black Lantern's it's a coming together
of every living being in existence to
fight off against the black Lantern's
and have it come to a head in a massive
battle Thal Sinestro is just one with
his own Lantern Corps he knows how to
use it in a way that nobody else does
Mongol is just this heavy hitter
he's just this Slugger that's really all
it is he's really really smart and he's
very capable but he's not a master of
the Sinestro Corps Sinestro actually
overpowers and eliminates
right off the bat and so what this does
is it basically leads into this idea
that we're going to see the return of
the Sinestro Corps and we're eventually
going to see a continued call to arms
all these Lantern cores coming together
to join the Earth's superheroes and face
off against the Black Lantern Corps
which will ultimately lead into the rise
of the white Lantern's but with that
being said guys we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comics explain and make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb pork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]